okay we'll talk about systems of linear
equations now remember that an equation
is the application of a rule so every
pair of numbers which satisfies that
equation satisfies the rule the
underlying function now you may well
have many different rules you may have
therefore many different conditions that
have to be satisfied and it's precisely
in analyzing problems with many
different rules that need to be
simultaneously satisfied that we use
systems of linear equations or
simultaneous equations actually systems
of equations they may not be linear
today we'll just talk about linear ones
okay so here we've got two equations y
equals 4x minus 14 and y equals x plus 5
I guess these are the equations we just
worked out solving this set of equations
we're just going to do an example with
two but there could be any number of any
finite number of equations that we might
need to solve solving means finding the
values of X&Y that's the pair of x and y
such that both equations are valid okay
so
when we're talking about linear
equations there are just three
possibilities that is there's a unique
solution when we're talking about linear
equations and we're only talking about
two equations no more than two then
there's either a unique solution that is
the two lines cross at exactly one point
because their linear they can only cross
once it's possible that they never cross
and why why might that be the case why
might they never cross yes what's your
name same slope same slope so they would
be parallel lines or there are
infinitely many solutions that is the
two lines happen to be exactly the same
they coincide it may not be obvious when
you look at the equations that they are
the same but when you plot out their
graphs you realize that they are the
same ok so the happy situation where you
have two equations that cross once with
a particular solution let's say the
solution is X star and y star X star
refers to a particular value of x y star
refers to a particular value of y ok ok
this is generally the kind of problem
we're trying to solve ok the graphical
method of solving works only when there
are two unknowns so and therefore two
equations you simply graph the two
equations the same way that we've done
so far and you look for the values of
X&Y where they intercept so
x star and y star this is the point of
intersection and here is the solution
for the two graphs that we just worked
out in the previous section okay okay of
course it's not convenient to always use
the graphical method so you might need
to substitute and so the way the
substitution method is is really a
process of illumination what you do is
you solve one of the equations so that
you have either X or Y alone on one side
so you're expressing X in terms of the
other variable Y or Y in terms of the
other variable X and then you substitute
that expression for X into your
remaining equation so that you end up
with one equation in one unknown and you
all know how to solve that algebraically
so a common technique in mathematics as
always to take a complex problem and to
reduce its complexity by one level and
then to take that simplified problem and
reduce the complexity by one level and
so on by a process of iteration okay two
thousand years ago people took a
lifetime to do this sort of thing
nowadays we have Excel or or MATLAB or
or other other iterative programs okay
okay so here we are simply trying to
solve the two equations these two
equations this one and that one via the
substitution method
okay so we've got y equals 4x minus 14
we actually don't need to do anything
here because we've got y expressed in
terms of X there's no y on the
right-hand side so we could simply take
this expression and substitute it into
the other equation the other equation is
y equals x plus 5 so instead of why i
have here for x minus 14 the reason we
put the star here is to indicate that
this equality only holds for a
particular value of x which satisfies
both equations ie this X star here right
so here I'm solving for a particular
value of x which is called X star and I
just algebraically manipulate till i get
x star is equal to six and a third okay
and then i could substitute x star back
into either into this equation or that
equation to get what why start so let's
let's do a quick application quick and
simple application and then we'll talk
about more interesting things okay so a
very common problem is is supply and
demand in economics we very often
describe the quantity supplied and the
quantity demanded in a marketplace as a
function of price price is the
independent variable the input variable
and quantity demanded or quantity
supplied is the dependent variable the
output variable now so far this is a
quick that you should get used to so far
i have always display
why on the vertical axis and X on the on
the horizontal axis and X was the input
variable and why was the output variable
for historical reasons economists have
always shown price on the vertical axis
even though it is the input variable and
quantity on the horizontal axis even
though quantity is actually the output
variable okay so generally all supply
and demand curves that you will see
look like this this is a demand curve
this is a supply curve and price is
actually the independent variable and
quantity demanded or supplied as a
function of price is the dependent
variable okay so that's why the way this
is the way this is shown the way I've
expressed this queue as a function of P
shows the underlying functional
relationship but Q is not on the y-axis
okay this is just a quick that sadly
creates all sorts of confusion so it's
just something to watch out for okay so
here suppose that we have a demand curve
quantity demanded is equal to 300 minus
6 p and quantity supplied is equal to
quarter p okay all the intuition that I
gave you earlier about a steep slope and
a shallow slope has to get reversed
because of this problem because this
really is a mirror image or
transformation so look at this this is
minus 6 p it would look like a large a
very steep negative slope but when you
draw it because the axes are reversed it
will look like a shallow negative slope
okay okay so when you try to when you
try to solve this you won't have to
worry about that you
have to worry about the geometric
intuition you simply carry out the
process of substitution that which we
talked about earlier okay so okay so
let's see so suppose that we have this
demand function in this supply function
and we want to find the point of
equilibrium well we can simply set the
demand function equal to the supply
function q d equals Q s and solve for P
or are the P star we get a value for P
or 48 a value for Q of 12 and we don't
we don't have to worry about what what
that looks like okay so yes any
questions no okay good ok I think we're
doing very well here so we're probably
going to finish early we have we're
going to talk about nonlinear functions
and okay so this is a repetition of a
slide from earlier on by definition a
nonlinear function is one whose slope
changes for different values of x by
definition linear function is one whose
slope is constant okay so this is a
nonlinear function this is a linear
function okay now in nonlinear functions
the slope is constantly changing and in
order to carry out analyses about
nonlinear functions which have
constantly changing slopes we could
simply do graphical analysis we could
simply if we
new the equation of the nonlinear
function we could draw a graph we could
plot a graph and find out its behavior
and that's that's one of the things that
you do before you start doing calculus
but because we can't always do that we
use calculus as a shorthand for
describing how the slope of a nonlinear
function changes so calculus liberate
sus from having to use graphical
techniques to describe the behavior of
nonlinear functions so think of calculus
as a set of rules that tell us that
provide a shorthand for how the slope of
the nonlinear function changes because
we know that it is constantly changing
ok ok examples of nonlinear functions a
power function ok a power function is a
function which has a constant power or
index for see this could this need not
be an integer it could be two or three
or it could be two point three to see
here could be 2.3 and that would be a
power function ok an example of a power
function here is a cubic function 2x
cubed a polynomial function when I'm
sure you've seen many times a polynomial
let's say of order 4 would be something
like a X to the 4 plus BX to the 3 plus
DX to the second plus X plus C ok and
here is an example of a Paul
niall to order to okay an interesting
function that we will use often in many
scientific applications and also in many
financial and economic applications is
the exponential function any function
that has X as an exponent ISM is an
exponential function so for example 2 to
the X would be an exponential function
the one exponential function that I've
given you here is a particularly special
exponential function called eat ooh the
x and e anybody here know what E is
named for or who he is named for not
Einstein but someone older than Einstein
not that old you clearly there's a good
good good try not that old leonhard
euler who actually i mentioned earlier
is the first one to define mathematical
functions what what is e anybody know
what that number is approximately 2.7
one right to some toten to two digits i
actually don't know how how what the
next digit is pretty okay the
logarithmic function you probably all
when you did mathematics in in high
school I don't know they still teach log
base 10
so you probably know that either but
this is not log to base 10 this is the
log to base E or the natural the log to
base 10 is not very not very useful
concept nowadays because everybody uses
calculators log to base 10 was often
used when people didn't have calculators
because it's a good it's a fast way to
do multiplication and division okay so
here is the here is the exponential
function you should get used to what
this function looks like it for so II to
the X when X is equal to 0 is 1 because
any number raised to the power 0 is
equal to 1 okay so the the y-intercept
is equal to 1 it is an exponentially
rising function so you'll see that it's
slope increases as x increases and you
know so it has a shape similar to other
exponential functions it has the feature
that its inverse is equal to the natural
log function and you should get used to
this shape too because it's very useful
in many applications and here you'll see
that it starts off at minus infinity for
X equal to 0 and Rises but unlike the
exponential function its slope gets more
shallow as x increases okay so that's a
useful
point to start thinking about inverse
functions okay so what's an inverse
function remember I said that a function
is a rule it assigns an output to an
input one thing that I left unstated is
that it assigns a unique output to an
input okay so it assigns a unique value
Y to each value of x it doesn't mean
that each value of y has associated with
it a unique value of x okay so that
means that two values of x could lead to
the same why but one value x is only
going to give you one why everybody see
that and pictorially
you
ok so let's say this is the number 10
so if if you give me an x value of 2 i'm
going to give you a y-value of 10 and
only 10 but if you give me another x
value i might also give you 10 whatever
x values you give me i'm only going to
give you one associated y value but if
you were to give me a y-value i may give
you more than one associated x value the
definition of a function and that's why
a function is not necessarily to where
write a function is a rule that takes X
as an input and gives you a unique value
Y as an output now a monotonic function
is one that's always increasing or
always decreasing is this a monotonic
function no right it sometimes
increasing sometimes decreasing so a
monotonic function would be one that
looked for example like that such as the
log function that I just showed you ok
now for monotonic functions you could
think of them as two-way rules because
if you have a monotonic function for
every value of y there is only a single
value of x that is associated with it ok
now the rule that it finds that single
or unique value of x to every value of y
is called the inverse function so you
could think of the inverse function as
the rule that reverses the effect of the
original function
so we started out with the function 2x
that's a rule that says give me X
multiply X by 2 and I'll give you an
output equal to 2x what's the rule that
reverses that function yeah x over to
write half x okay so if Y is equal to
two x then x is equal to y over 2 so I
just switched the notation so as to keep
it simple so as to keep x and y in the
same domains but you could certainly say
x over 2 also okay okay now is there an
inverse function for the function y
equals x squared I'm sure you remember
this dilemma from so anybody remember
the the graph of x squared right this is
x squared okay so what's the inverse of
this function okay so we have one vote
four square root of x any other case of
x square root of Y okay so that
certainly reverses the process of
squaring
it could be minus right so remember this
is not a monotonic function so the
natural inclination to reverse the rule
doesn't work in this case because we
don't have a monotonic function because
there are negative 4x in the negative
domain they also give you this x squared
so you can't simply reverse it because
remember for an inverse function to
exist it has to be that for every value
of y I have only a unique value of x so
here I now have two potential values of
x so when i take the square root there
are two potential routes right there's a
plus and a minus root so taking the
square root it is not actually a
function since it gives me two answers
to potential answers right and so that's
why an inverse function doesn't exist
for 4x squared and so you know and you
might say well this is our king you know
why do I care about this but the kinds
of places you you'll certainly see it
used but I'll give you a flavor for it
now generally when you observe phenomena
and you think that there's some
relationship between one phenomenon and
another you you will be in situations
where you only observe one phenomenon
and don't observe the other okay so for
example you'll only observe why and not
X and so you have to surmise what X
might have been
if you are sure about the rule the
function then and you are and you're
able to work out an inverse then you
will be able to surmise what that X is
if if you are in a problem where there
is no inverse because there are multiple
ways of getting to that why that you
observed then you won't be able to
conclude the presence of X just by
observing why ok so this looks very dry
and technical but it has very very real
example a very real applications and
another you know a place where you see
this a lot is of course in law right so
this is directly related to the
prosecutors policy if you see you know
if you see some some set of acts which
are circumstantially linked then you
think that a certain person has
committed a crime but in criminal law of
course you have to have a very high
standard of proof and it may well be
that there are a number of potential
hypotheses which are correct that would
be exactly the same as not having an
inverse function multiple x's that give
you the same why ok and that's exactly
how it is used in science and you'll see
that hopefully in your classes ok ok
let's keep going so the inverse function
I had given you the exponential function
and the long function these two are
related in that the natural log is the
inverse of the
exponential function and vice versa okay
and you can see this when you put the
two next to each other just imagine for
a second that I would have rotate if i
were to strip this white square out from
the screen out this way so i would take
this point and put it somewhere here
this is not you pull it out towards you
okay and then i would to turn it around
so that the ex ended up up here and the
y ended up down here of course this
would end up looking just like that
notice that this cross is the y axis at
one this crosses the x-axis and one okay
and this goes off towards minus infinity
as does this okay this is actually
actually this is not drawn at y equal to
0 which is why this looks like it's
touching but it shouldn't be touching in
other words this the height of this is
not zero it it's something higher than
zero okay okay okay quickly an implicit
function very often and this is this
this is more of a computational problem
rather than a semantic distinction like
the one between the inverse function an
implicit function often usually and so
far we've defined all functions
explicitly that is y is equal to x
squared plus X minus 10 let's say but
sometimes you will have two variables
related in a very complex way and it's
it's difficult to take one of the
variables and put it on one side and
strip it away so you might have
something that looks like this this is a
function of x and y this is an
expression that includes x and y and
that's equal to a particular number so
you'd have to put y on one side or x on
one side but if you did that if you try
to do that you'd have to solve a
third-order polynomial for y and a
second-order polynomial for x so you'd
end up with a complicated expression on
the right-hand side with many roots and
of course as you know from our
discussion about roots roots don't have
unique values and so you wouldn't end up
with an actual function okay however
however this condition nevertheless
defines a set of X's and Y's which meet
that condition okay and very often they
will have some graph even though that
graph may not be the graph of a function
a very common implicitly defined
function is
anybody know what the graph of this
implicitly defined function looks like a
circle right okay so that's not a
function for any value of x I have two
potential values of Y it certainly
doesn't have an inverse I have the same
problem but nevertheless this condition
is useful because it limits the sets of
paired X wise which satisfy that
condition and so once again you might
observe phenomena in the world which
satisfy this condition it may not follow
a functional rule but it tells you or it
limits the set of observations that you
might expect to see okay okay so keep
implicit functions in mind once you have
calculus you are able to do some things
with implicit functions in particular
you're able to determine rules which
tell you what the slope of that locus of
points is at a particular value of x or
y okay and that may be a useful piece of
information
you